[موسيقى]
أنت تأكل أشياء مثل المكسرات ، فهم
يأكلون الخضر وليس فقط السبانخ أو اللفت ،
هناك المئات من الوسائل التي تجعلهم يأكلون
الكثير منها يحتوي على عشرة أضعاف
مضادات الأكسدة الموجودة في النبيذ الأحمر ، وهي أهم
عنصر هوية في العالم كله
نستخدمه إذا  نتناول كوبًا من
الفاصوليا يوميًا ربما يضيف حوالي
أربع سنوات إلى حامل متوسط العمر المتوقع في مح
ولة للحصول على البروتين أو ال
حم البقري عندما يتعلق الأمر بالحبوب أعتقد أن ال
مريكيين مرتبكون ، لقد در
ت الأطول والنسور وخ
س مناطق  لمدة 20 عامًا
، يأكل الناس الحبوب بشكل كبير كل
يوم ، لكنهم حبوب كاملة ، والناس هنا
بطاقات ويذهبون يا إلهي ، حسنًا ، نعم إذا كانت
الكربوهيدرات تأتي من
الكعك والكعك والخبز الأبيض ، فهذه
جيدة ، والكربوهيدرات السيئة تحصل على
الكربوهيدرات.  سمعة سيئة في Blue Zones ،
لا يمارس الناس أبدًا حالة فارغة دون
التفكير على الرغم من أنهم سيعطونك
نشاطًا بدنيًا وصالة ألعاب رياضية يعيشون في
أماكن يذهبون فيها إلى العمل
أو يذهبون إليه في كل مرة.  الأصدقاء في المنزل مع
المناسبات والمشي ونضيف
حرق السعرات الحرارية عندما تفعل شيئًا
كل 20 دقيقة ، فهو يفوق بكثير ما كنت
ستحصل عليه إذا جلست في مكتبك طوال
اليوم ثم توقعت تعويضه عن
نصف الكل في  نادي رياضي